who is Elon Musk going to vote for for
president see yourself voting for
President Biden if if it's if a Biden
Trump election for
example I think I would not vote for
Biden you'd vote for Trump I'm not
saying I'd vote for Trump but I
mean this is this is definitely a
difficult Choice here you know would you
would you vote for Nikki Haley Nikki
Haley by the way wants uh all social
media
um names to be exposed as you know no I
think that's outrageous yeah no I'm not
going to vote for some Pro censorship
candidate so what do we conclude from
this it means that look maybe he'll just
vote for Trump and he's just trying to
be kg about it I think Elon is
expressing something deeper here which
is that he opposes the old consensus and
Nicki Haley fairly or unfairly has
become a representative of the old
consensus